sharpen those swords and top off those
potions because the witcher 3 is getting
another patch and best of all is
available now while the witcher 3 wild
hunt is not getting an enhanced edition
the open-world RPG is changing very soon
CD Projekt RED is announced at the
witcher 3 s 1.12 patch is out now across
xbox one playstation 4 and pc the news
comes from community manager martian
limo unfortunately CD Projekt RED aren't
adding any big new feature to this time
around but the update should fix bugs
glitches and improve the overall
performance of both the main game and
hearts of stone the latest expansion
some of the changes include improved
quest tracking across regions a series
of minor difficulty balance tweaks at
all difficulty levels in hearts of stone
and an enhancement we're ingredients
required for a pinned formula are now
highlighted in said merchants shop
screen for a full list of changes head
over to GameSpot's article or the CD
Projekt RED calm the witcher 3 wild hunt
launched in May last year and we give it
a 10 out of 10 and even named it our
2015 game of the year for more on The
Witcher and all things gaming you're
already in the right place